let's talk a little bit about
reproduction
now on earth and who knows if we go to
other planets we might find new ways
that organisms can reproduce but on
earth there's two primary ways that
organisms reproduce the first is is that
let's say this is some type of
unicellular organism
it essentially just makes a copy of
itself so that's it there and then
that's its copy and in this situation
they have identical genetic materials so
let's say this is genetic material in
the first one and this is the first one
to begin with and now you have the
second one
now this type of reproduction when one
organism by itself can turn into two
organisms this is known as asexual
asexual
reproduction
or another way to interpret asexual is
it is not sexual so the next question is
what is sexual reproduction this is
where two organisms or at least cells
from two organisms need to get together
in order to produce a third organism
here is a cell from one of the organisms
let's say that cell is from the mother
it could be an egg cell
here's a cell from the other organism
let's call that organism the father this
would be a sperm cell and when the egg
and the sperm get together when they
fuse together they have genetic
information from both parents and that
new cell can become the offspring and if
sexual reproduction sounds familiar it's
because that's how you came to be
now to make this a little bit more
tangible let's look at some cases of
asexual reproduction and sexual
reproduction so right over here we see a
diagram of a type of asexual
reproduction known as binary fission
in general if you hear the word fission
we're talking about splitting something
if people are talking about nuclear
fission they're talking about splitting
of the atom but binary fission we're
talking about one organism splitting
into two organisms and you can see that
you have its genetic material the
genetic material it replicates and then
the organism splits into two identical
organisms or at least identical from a
genetic point of view now binary fission
applies to prokaryotes that we talk
about in other videos these are
organisms that don't have
organelles that don't have a nuclear
membrane they don't tend to have
multiple chromosomes when we talk about
eukaryotes things that do have nuclear
membranes things that have multiple
chromosomes things that have
membrane-bound organelles you have a
similar type of reproduction
this right over here and we'll study it
in depth in biology this is mitosis
and mitosis you can view it as the
analog of binary fission but we're now
dealing with eukaryotic cells eukaryotic
cells are more complex so this process
is more complex but at a high level they
are both asexual reproduction in both
cases one cell or one organism in some
case has turned into two organisms that
have the same genetic information and
it's worth calling out when you take one
organism and you produce another
organism with the same genetic
information it has a word associated
with it and that is a clone and you
might be familiar with the term clone
from science fiction movies and they
usually use it in a somewhat related
context in star wars when they talk
about the clone wars all of those clones
they all have the same genetic
information as the original bounty
hunter from which they were derived
now mitosis might also seem familiar to
you because this is how most of your
cells in your body divide and this is
how you grow this is how you went from
being a unicellular organism to being a
multicellular organism now you might be
a little bit confused at this point i
just told you that most of your cells
have experienced or are experiencing
mitosis but you're also the outcome of
sexual reproduction well what we'll see
in a second is as soon as sexual
reproduction occurs then this newly
formed cell right over here through
mitosis forms the multicellular
organisms the types that are you and me
but we also as we grow and develop we
also produce what are known as gametes
that each have half of our genetic
information for human beings this would
be the egg produced by a female and this
would be the sperm produced by a male
and when they get together the sperm
fertilizes the egg well then they can
produce a viable cell that can turn into
an offspring
now along the lines of binary fission
you have another type of asexual
reproduction in which case a mother cell
produces buds off a smaller daughter
cell so like binary fission it has to
replicate all of its dna and then that
dna gets inserted into the daughter cell
but the end product you have a bigger
cell and a smaller cell and we would say
that the smaller cell has budded off of
this larger one and so this we call
budding
another form of asexual reproduction
when we think about multicellular
organisms there are some typical types
of asexual reproduction for example
starfish are famous for their ability to
form a new organism from a piece of an
original organism so let's say you were
to cut that part off of the starfish for
many species of starfish that could then
grow into a new starfish and the
original starfish would grow that back
and so this type of reproduction is
known as fragmentation
it's pretty easy to fragmentation
it's pretty easy to remember you take a
fragment of it and it grows into another
organism and that's how it reproduces
now another fascinating type of
reproduction is known as parthenogenesis
and it's a fancy word
parthenoparthenogenesis
and what happens here is is you have an
organism and this is a baby komodo
dragon right over here that can develop
from an unfertilized egg remember in
sexual reproduction we talk about how a
sperm from a father organism needs to
fertilize an egg from a mother organism
and then once they fuse together then
that fertilized egg can go through
mitosis to produce a multicellular
organism but in parthenogenesis you have
an egg
on its own that can that does not need
to be fertilized that can turn into a
multi multicellular organism like a baby
komodo dragon now you might ask well how
can this be
well sometimes these mother these eggs
don't have half the genetic material
like we're used to with the eggs from
sexual reproduction
for parthenogenesis many times this egg
has a complete set of genetic
information and then it can just go and
start doing mitosis and turn to an
organism or there's even situations
where the egg does have half the genetic
information we'll talk about this in
future videos this would be a haploid
cell it has half the genetic information
of its parent but the haploid cell in
certain cases can develop into a full
organism and there are organisms like
komodo dragons that can reproduce both
with parthenogenesis which would be
asexual and in certain cases with sexual
reproduction
so i'll leave you there two big
categories i'll draw a dividing line
here so we don't get confused all the
stuff that i drew on the left to the
left of this yellow line these are forms
of asexual reproduction where for the
most part one organism can make a copy
of itself that has the same genetic
information
on the right we have sexual reproduction
where in order to produce a new organism
an egg cell and a sperm cell need to get
together the sperm cell needs to
fertilize the egg cell and each of them
would have a sample of half of the
genetic information from their parents
now i'll leave you with a final question
and we should always be asking this in
biology is why do we think sexual
reproduction emerged it actually emerged
much later in our evolutionary history
than asexual reproduction
well one argument for it is it produces
much more variation in its offspring and
if you have more variation in your
offspring and if you have more variation
in a population you have a higher
likelihood that certain variations will
be better suited for the environment
that you are in
i'll let you think about that a little
bit more